uh let's talk about fear-mongering I'm
not someone who thinks that there's
nothing to be afraid of in modern 2016
society on earth Donald Trump has used
fear in his campaign to try to get
people to vote for him he's used fear of
Hispanic immigrant rapists criminals
he's used fear of Muslims he's used fear
of Hillary Clinton fear of her allegedly
poor health or fear of her lack of
trustworthiness or whatever he's used
fear of liberal ideas he's also used
fear of black criminals and he's made a
number of aspects of that sort of
central over the last few weeks to his
supposed outreach to black voters and he
actually went further this week and
started making a case based on pure lies
let me show you and read to you a tweet
that Donald Trump put out this week
saying inner-city crime is reaching
record levels African Americans will
vote for Trump because they know i will
stop the slaughter going on first of all
this is part of this bizarre outreach to
black americans which as i mentioned has
led Trump really in a rough spot with as
I'll tell you later on in today's show
zero percent favorability among black
Americans in a recent poll there are
sort of two questions that need to be
asked with every single one of trumps
claims number one is if the claims are
true then is this something that Donald
Trump would improve as president but
there's a different question that we
must ask which is is the claim even true
and with this this uh tweet about
inner-city crime at record levels it's
not even close to the truth first of all
there's no actual official category for
what an inner city is so PolitiFact
evaluated this claim and they looked at
cities with a population of over 250,000
that's how they define large cities the
truth is and this is using FBI data this
isn't Obama data it's not Trump data
it's not Hillary Clinton data this is
FBI data when you look at the crime rate
the the rate not the number of crimes in
these
major cities it has actually been on the
decline if you go back to the early to
mid-1990s and just look at the trend
line we have seen crime decline in major
cities if we look more specifically at
homicide rates those have also been
declining nationally since the early to
mid-1990s there are and this is where
you know sometimes Trump will sort of
grab on to the littlest sliver of
something that could be distorted to
maybe make it seem like there's some
truth there over the last year there is
a group of cities that have seen an
uptick in crime over the last year when
you look at the trendline nationally for
all cities over 250,000 in population
the violent crime rate the homicide rate
the total crime rate has been decreasing
so we've never actually lived in a time
where we've seen such sustained
decreases in the crime rate decreases in
violence if you look at the world and
compare it now to a hundred years ago to
two hundred years ago to five hundred
years ago a thousand years ago a
relatively small percentage of the world
population is dealing with war zones a
relatively smaller percentage of the
world population is in what we would
call extreme poverty now I'm not saying
it's all glorious sunshine and ginger
snaps and waterfalls that's not what I'm
saying what I am saying is that the
problems we're dealing with today
legitimate problems are problems we've
made significant progress on and Jason
Trump is just fear mongering with fall
statistics and the the the part that
really bothers me is people aren't
questioning the statistics they're going
straight to here's how Trump would fix
it when sometimes it doesn't really
exist at least not as Trump is
suggesting and I think what this is the
case kind of sort of like a sports team
where a manager gets credit for all
those players doing so well and it's not
really you know he doesn't really
influence its I know one news story I
heard yesterday was how the Spain's uh
you know government is in not in session
now because of this big debajo going on
over they
and their economy has finally been on
the uptick for the first time in five
years not actually related to a break
from legislative session and this also
applies to Trump wants to attach I don't
even think Trump really knows the
numbers but there are some who want to
attach the crime increase in some cities
over the last year to President Obama
specifically and of course we know that
number one you can't do that the same
way that gas prices can't be directly
connected to the individual decisions
made by president but in addition to
that it ignores the broader trend not
only over the nearly eight years of
President Obama's presidency but dating
back 20 or 30 years now so this stuff
will rot your brain before you start to
think about whether Trump is the
solution to the problem figure out
whether he's even accurately
representing the problem and this is in
the midst of really really serious issue
with climate change where we should be
acting corporations getting even more
power if TPP were to pass medical and
scientific progress being stunted by
religious ideologues an economy were
income inequality continues to grow
there are real things to be afraid of
Donald Trump saying inner-city crime is
at an all-time high and he'll fix it
that is not one of those things I've
talked about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com slash david support our
show reduce your carbon emissions and
you're spending on cars sign up at
joined zipcar dot-com slash david